I said well what about you know we're
going to make sure Humanity's okay here
um and and and
um uh and then he called me a speciest
this is Elon Musk uh a little while ago
talking about Google co-founder Larry
Page uh because uh Larry pagee basically
believes well believed or maybe still
believes uh that you can basically
create God through Ai and the question
that Elon poses really I think we are
all going to have to think about as as
AI becomes more and more ubiquitous and
as I said yesterday as the as Skynet
turns on are you pro-human or anti-human
do you think computers can create gods
and we should just be little cogs in
their system or do you think that there
is something uniquely important about
being a human well I think I probably
know what you think and I think you
definitely know what I think anyway take
a look I mean the the reason open ey
exists at all is that um Larry Paige and
I used to be close friends and I would
stay at his house in pal Alto and I
would talk to him late into the night
about uh AI safety and at least my
perception was that Larry was not taking
uh AI safety seriously enough um and um
what did he say about it he really
seemed to be um one want want sort of
digital super intelligence basically
digital God if you will and at one point
uh I said well what about you know we're
going to make sure humanity is okay here
um and and and um uh and then he called
me a
speciest did he use did he use that term
yes and there were Witnesses I wasn't
the only one there when you called me a
speciest and so I was like okay that's
it uh I've yes I'm a speciest okay you
got
me what are
you yeah I'm fully aous
um busted
um so um that was the last rooll all
right so that's our last video today and
I think you got what I did there that
Elon Musk the people that are fighting
for Humanity who are fighting for the
West who are fighting for Freedom it's
not just that we have to fight Hamas
it's not just that we have to fight all
the indoctrination and the woke and the
stuff that melee is doing down in
Argentina and all of those things but we
have other fights on the way we are
literally going to have to fight the
robots and the people that want to
create digital gods and I get it it's
all a lot but if you are pro-human you
should be anti- Hamas you should be
anti-mainstream media you should be well
you should be a spe species right you
should be because we're a species and I
would like to see us continue to
thrive pick the good guys pick the bad
guys pick a side the the time of
choosing is now man the time of choosing
was a while back
but it is uh it is definitely
on